simon we're in your hands perhaps you
firstly are we starting with your budget
papers five six eight onwards
correct thank you mr me good afternoon
good afternoon
um well it has been so far
let's just continue to be the bureau of
goods
and it'll go well it's beginning to warm
up
[Laughter]
but as we stand between you and the end
of the day i leave it in your hands
that's what i say to colleagues all the
time
uh so first of the strategy engagement
budgets
up relates to strategic projects which
now with some change in budget
structures and reporting
as myself and simon and jeff are
covered in this budget which covers a
policy and strategy
unit the business and centers units and
and the costs that go with myself
so i probably would just like to
highlight um the the budget numbers are
essentially
status quo in the sense that it's
existing staffing and it's
predominantly staffing and there are not
huge material changes in the amounts
other than uh you know what has been
assumed in relation to things like
training and such like
i would like um uh jeff to just
kind of highlight what we see as some of
the issues
and risks to consider we're not seeking
at this time a response to that but we
just need you to be aware of those as we
go into 2021
i guess what we're anticipating is a
central government agenda
because a reform agenda that will
keep us fairly busy as a council in
terms of being able to respond
to central government initiatives in
particular
the reform of the resource management
act is something
which is very high on the agenda for the
to this government and there'll be two
major pieces of legislation to
replace the rma so we need to keep on
our toes
we don't think that there's going to be
any pre-consultation we just think that
there's going to be
draft legislation and go straight into a
select committee process
so unlike the climate change legislation
of the previous
three years where we had an opportunity
to
go through a consultative process we
don't anticipate that that will occur
with the rma reform already the randison
report has gone through
that sort of public consultation so
the government's intention is to
implement the randison review
and so there won't be a great deal of
opportunity to
have input apart from through the select
committee process
coupled with that is a fairly busy
program from the regional council as
well
they've already flagged that they
intend to have a revision of the
regional policy statement
and the regional coastal plan so
they've got budget from ecan to
undertake those
reforms and those reviews so
we need to keep on our toes in terms of
a response from this council in relation
to that
the other thing on the horizon from my
perspective is that
we've often responded to productivity
commission inquiries
and the productivity commissioners
is dependent on getting instructions
from the minister for finance
and there's been a brand new chair to
the productivity commission appointed
in ganesh nana now ganesh would probably
be familiar to a lot of us because
he headed up the bureau of economic
research limited
and now he's been appointed as the chair
of the productivity commission
so that will give a
a helpful sort of entree because he's
very familiar with
local government having been
appointed by soldier over the years to
do
kind of the the price level of justice
uh
on a regular basis so i'm anticipating
that
quite a bit more activity from the
productivity commission too
as uh the government looks at new
zealand's productivity and some of the
inquiries that might come from the
minister for finance
um i just very briefly add to that of
course we know three waters
reform process will be moving at pace
during this year
there will be identification of what the
entities are going to be
around march april there'll be a
mandatory
consultation to be done with the
community later in the year but it
suspends all the ordinary
consultation processes that there are
under the local government act
so there will be a bill to amend the lga
that will need to go to select committee
that
truncates the engagement that will
happen around the three water reforms
to require councils to consult on the
basis of a standard national
proposal so we will have views about
that
so and then of course there is an
emerging agenda
of the future of local government in the
general sense
so there will be a new steering group
between government uh solgum
and lgmz and that work stream will be
getting underway
at quite a pace so look all we're trying
to do take the opportunity while we've
all got you
to just highlight at the beginning of
the year and we won't
we'll try not to come come at you with
surprises
but but articulate a program that will
be an
extensive program of consideration of
pretty fundamental issues around local
government through
2021 and 2022 and we'll obviously be
doing our best
within the limits of the resourcing that
we do have
to provide you the opportunity to
articulate yourselves as a council
but also probably ultimately more
importantly on behalf of a community
um what is in the best interest of the
waimakariri community through all of
that
and at times you are going to be
frustrated because you will not have the
opportunity to test community views on
this
so that's not a
intentionally a gun to your head but it
is that we're going to be
in for a pretty rocky ride in 2021
on a whole range of fronts apart from
all of the day job and
getting and delivering the programs that
you want to have delivered
for the community um so with that um
simon i'm not sure if there's any more
introduction you considered the
town centre's program report this
morning and we thank you for
um for uh deciding that as a program
because that really
helps us as an organization as staff but
also the community
get a sense of intent and momentum that
is multi-year
and undoubtedly uh within that program
timings and scale of projects
will as new information comes to hand
change
but it is then able to be considered
within a framework
rather than blow by blow and so it saves
you
and i think the community and us
it's an efficient way of working but
still with all of the requisite
accountabilities in place sign many
things
i'm so happy to answer any questions on
the
budget amounts for what's still called
strategy and engagement
on pages five seven four three two
five seven six
any questions thanks simon simon jeff
any questions
[Music]
great okay oh sorry hot off please
i just can't see any efficiencies you've
got here compare
all yours big increases on everything
but no um
no extra things you're doing what you
normally do outcome can be
so much deerer on your forecast
and not see anything extra getting from
the lord
so thank you for the question councillor
so the core costs
are the existing staff complement
and there is no additional staff there's
no lease staff
so these are costs that go with the
current program
built into this budget however are
increases that are reflected out of the
town centre's program of work that you
approved this morning
so there are there are some lines here
that are that are increased as a result
of that
but if you have specific lines that
you're interested in
happy to answer questions on that
the accommodation cost seems to be uh
greater than what
other area have from 68 000 budget to
budget 21 22 to 77.
so i that's no that's the start that's a
question
that relates to the property budget in
terms of
the way that overhead is spread so i
have no control over that
i'm not criticizing that budget but it
is determined outside of this
and it's an amount that is inserted into
this budget
so i think the time for discussion of
the accommodation costs and allocations
is tomorrow
thank you any other questions or any
general comments
but simon can i just uh i've been saying
the stuffs we've been going through
but there has been a particularly busy
year and
i know i've really appreciated the
support that as a council we get from a
strategic policy perspective now there's
not
nothing that we aren't well briefed on
uh or that you haven't thought of in
advance whether i need to call on some
advice or assistance with submissions
that we've had to do at the drop of a
hatch
really appreciated that jeff has
certainly helped me with a number of
select committee
submissions and that was a new learning
curve for me because i hadn't done them
before so um
i really appreciated that support that
we get to the greater christchurch work
and that's where you really add your
value simon in general but
you're not your relationships and they
are
really important to us to understand and
unpick some of that work that we're
doing so
thank you very much to you and the team
for what you do we've acknowledged simon
and vanessa and
others this morning in their space too
but i
know increasingly that our developers
and people that are working in the space
do appreciate that
advice that they're getting so uh in
that work that's being done so thank you
to you and your team
really appreciate it
yes yep
[Music]
it's a 4.7 that's tab nine uh and
diligent team
thank you that's the covert 19 recovery
thank you simon
thank you so yes this is the covert
recovery
program update and uh the purpose of
this report is really just to provide a
general update on the overarching
economic environment
as we navigate our way through uh level
one still
in the in the new zealand covert
environment
the report also importantly lists the 27
recovery actions uh that we have
and lists some progress against those
actions along with some recommendations
as a
as to whether we should continue or
discontinue each one of those
27 actions the report also talks a
little bit
about the community team's great work in
the social recovery space
and the recommendations in the report
seek to support some of that continued
work
you'll note that there was a successful
bid for up to seven hundred
thousand dollars of central government
funding
for the project shown in section 4.16 of
the report
uh there is a bid into the department of
internal affairs
for around a hundred thousand for
facilitation of that
that program of work um you'll note also
in the recommendations that we have made
provision for up to three hundred
thousand dollars
of additional funding from the covered
recovery fund
that is to support uh a few things
one one is that if we don't if we're not
successful in that
uh application to the department of
internal affairs
we would be able to cover that there's
some project management funding that is
potentially required for the kaiapoi hub
and there's also some impacts on the
aquatic facilities operation that that
money would also help cover of course we
we won't draw
down on that that funding uh without
coming back to council
to define exactly what that is uh close
when we're aware of those those numbers
and the application results
uh section four in addition to covering
some economic environment
information talks a little bit about the
unemployment and workforce under
utilization
along with beneficiary numbers in the
district up to quarter three 2020
section 4.22 that's the table of the 27
projects about eight of those projects
we're suggesting should be placed on
hold or discontinued
uh for multiple reasons some some of
those projects have been superseded by
other work
some of them were aimed at
seeing seek we put out there to see
whether the economic recovery advisory
group would support some of those they
haven't necessarily supported them and
we don't think that it's appropriate to
continue them
and some some relate to enc work as well
the enterprise north canterbury work
that that's in there so
um we've we've put forward those
recommendations to continue the majority
but
discontinue some of those happy to take
any questions that counselors might have
about
about that report in general thank you
any questions
council blackie can you comment a bit
further on
only only you only utilizing seven
hundred thousand
of the two
every time we pick up a newspaper we see
the all the well
the welfare agencies are at their limits
food banks sally's
you name it why have we only
allocated a third of the money we have
to allocate
are you keeping more in reserve um i
might default to jim
or jeff and that what i understand was
that the total
anticipated funding initially through
our covert projections
for uh council-related activities and
covert was around 2.1 million
of that we've only drawn down 700 000
and
that's how i understand it yeah so when
we put together that budget of 2.1 that
was to
anticipate continuing you know
continuing covert
events uh funding
shortfalls and things like aquatic
facilities
possibly our building building
consenting business
our pdu and water unit
weren't able to run at full capacity and
we're not eligible for subsidy for any
of that from the government wage subsidy
so
carrying and holding some of that cost
plus possibly
some economic interventions and support
to the local
community one form or another that's we
put a finger in the air and said well
that's something to give us a bit of
uh to come and go on and thankfully and
we're all
touching with flat tech that we don't
that we i haven't needed as much of that
and b we hope we don't so
now to be fair since we put that
together today's risk profile doesn't
isn't the same as the risk profile we
had when we
develop this budget and so there is a
risk between now
and deliberation time that
uh things go south and we might
you you like we did last year
need to rethink about what our plan
looks like and
that that remains a real risk for this
process so
if things carry on as they are and we
don't end up back in lockdown down
then we're not seeing a large draw where
our business
units are generally returning
or performing well uh
pools i think it down just a bit but
there's
there's more things and just covered
around that but offset building and
resource consent activity is
at levels which um we'd be quite happy
if they're a bit lower
so um yeah
that's a brief summary okay
that money was actually intended for for
well it's just direct welfare
cut benefit any payments is that correct
and
what from what you're saying no one's
asking no one's asking you for
for additional funding we had the
economic recovery advisory group
and it was anticipated that some of that
may need to be applied to initiatives
whether it was promotion for business or
or support in one form or another and we
admit
i was going to say regularly but
periodically
and the group has really not identified
any particular
need that it feels intervention by
council would be
beneficial or needed so no we haven't
made any direct
payment but simon was going to make some
observation there
um it wasn't so much in relation to
that particular question um per se but
just to note that
we are intending for the economic
recovery advisory group to meet again in
march
we sort of pretty much agree that with
those folk
back end of last year and
you've confirmed some funding for us to
substantially refresh our
economic economic development strategy
and it may well be that that the e-reg
group functions in the future is
like a reference group to that work
stream since it's very
very aligned and provides a a pretty
good forum of
giving current um strategic level
um kind of business perspective um
for as we try and um uh
articulate that albeit in a time that's
still pretty
high level of uncertainty as to how
we're going to track
alan in general i get quite a number of
requests through the office for specific
support for people who are in
particularly difficult circumstances
a lot of instances we through networks
can find them funding or find support
for them or advocate for them
so lions are a really good source rotary
and other organizations
i've got a small very small mineral
relief fund
um and i have used that a couple on a
couple of occasions
where i can't find support elsewhere for
some people
enough for firewood and and the likes
look there was a case just before
christmas of a very desperate couple
that had gone everywhere
and what made a real difference to their
life was actually buying them a washing
machine
it was four hundred dollars so a
very limited amounts that we can help
but we generally find
support on a welfare since through
working with tessa and the team and
pope trusts and the other organisations
to support people
when they when we're aware of the help
that they require so
that's the just to give you a snapshot
of the sort of welfare related measures
that come by that
we can help people with shout out there
to the um
community team with tessa they are
extremely well networked
and if they can sniff out some money
they will yeah they do it
tessa and the team do a absolutely
fantastic job
all right any other questions oh sorry
just just a few minutes to me i'll just
um i just note and just proves that i do
read things
um in recommendation g notes that the
notes should this application be
unsuccessful or not
is unsuccessful
[Music]
yeah okay all right when you're moving
that you'll um
move that mystery yeah
i didn't think there was any other
questions um all right would you like to
speak
no no not really just to say well look
thanks and
and you've obviously kept the purse
strings very close to your to our heart
on our behalf so thank you for that and
um
hopefully i did wonder at one point
whether there should be another line in
there that does cover us between now and
deliberation
um that says we could draw on this
and and it's i suppose that's a question
now um
you jumped the uh recommendation on me
mr mayor um
whether we should have something and
then it's just a bit of a backstop
between then and
now and then without having to come back
here to do something if something did
happen
we would probably be talking with you
one way or another between now and then
and even getting an informal nod
to any expenditure from this fund and
ratifying it afterwards if that occurred
adrian you adrian you picked up the
change to g
yes um casabella well just very quickly
to say
is i'm on the scw committee so
i hear about a lot of the groups who've
and and the money's been there
and these people are just amazing at
finding money and
tess is one of them um but all of the
team that everything from
cowboy community trust wellbeing oxford
community trust all of them
um they the money was there they were
very onto it
and they've received an awful lot of
money for the community so much so that
actually some of the food banks were
saying no no
don't give us food just at the moment
just hold off for a bit
so that's it really really great that
we've had that support in our district
that we've had people in place
and the networks in place to be able to
get that going and a lot of that is due
to our community team
so it's a huge kudos to them and um huge
kudos to simon
for leading the way and thank you for
taking on that that role
um we've had a share of disasters and
and
opportunities in the last um 10 years
and it's just so great to see how agile
we can be
and how with our leadership team and
without with starving and with that
council that we can actually get on and
do something so quickly
um and i'm sure that will happen if
anything else crops up which i'm hoping
it won't
any further speakers council duty so
thank you very much but we also would
like
really to mention for our communities
help
they all step up and help and that's
really important
so um we're we're in a healthy
situation living in the waimakariri
although we have some people that are
really struggling but we've got a lot of
people that are ready to put their hands
out to help
okay you fear the speakers right
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carry great
thanks simon and jeff simon you can stay
yeah okay come forward to the stand
that's right
swear on the bible
[Laughter]
so team pages five seven eight
um aleister
welcome if you want to take us through
the highlights of your report and
anything you want to draw to our
attention
page five so if you you're good um
this very much is a uh a rollover budget
um there are there are no new items
added to the budget for
for this year as the the majority of
changes went through
in the previous annual plan
oh you used the mic sorry thank you
say thanks to the council look in the
last
couple of years with with alastair's
um significant involvement we've
refreshed the
communications and engagement framework
we've brought in house graphic design
with
you've committed funding to support
communications around the district plan
review and major projects
we've got a great team of really good
people and we're achieving some
economies
with in-house delivery of graphic design
and in-house resourcing of our district
plan
related communications rather than
engaging
contractors so i think the team is
right sized at this point in time
and we've management team was
pleased to get a briefing from alastair
and zara around the current project
which is
the rework of
our existing website which is getting
very cluttered and
clumsy at that high level
and also preparing that for clearer
delineation of people coming to our
website for service
as opposed to information as opposed to
engagement
and seeking to customize that
significant presence to
whether you're a resident whether you're
a business
a visitor what what do you want to do
today so that's a project that will come
back to you during the year
through neville as the portfolio holder
for further uh discussion pleased to
answer any questions
thank you any questions cassidy
oh you're just uh enthusiastically
waving your hand
excellent council stuart
thank you um just um i note that the
um the graphic design
is in in-house you've got
an extra 60k um
what what have you actually saved by
bringing it in the house rather than
outsourcing
um so when uh when i put that through uh
last year what i did was i looked at the
average spend year on year with
an external agency we'd been using
called beck and call
and uh on average we were spending about
117 000
a year on uh graphic design through them
having someone in-house we can get
through
so far what seems through three times
the amount of work for a
significantly lower cost thank you
is that a question this time council
david yes
or just you've got a question
use the mic please thank you yes i'm
just wondering if perhaps
for them at some counts so it's sometime
in the for the council
if you'd like to bring your team in just
to say hello to us and
and just um give us an update i'd
appreciate that
yeah yeah i'd be more than happy to i've
got a briefing
with you guys in early march so i'll
bring the team along to that
excellent do any other questions
so any general comments
well i've been saying this to all staff
but um
i do get a lot of support from you one
to one alistar um
uh and i do appreciate the advice and
the quality of advice that there's a lot
that we don't realize just the level of
media or inquiry we get
um we probably do appreciate that but um
it's well all well managed and within
the team um there's a really good
environment
i see down near alistar and the quality
of work and even the design work
that's coming through it's clear and
even through the covert period
all that um the support that was given
and all that extra communication week so
it is certainly appreciated and i
remember when i first came on board
those that were around at that time
we had a very minimal communication
resource
effective fini to where we are now and
just looking at the quality of
of that support we get the website's
well overdue so i'm really pleased that
that's
being addressed and look forward to
further updates
on that from from you and the team and
good luck with that project because
it's it's important that resource for us
thanks alistair
samia um there's just one uh report
that's relevant
uh not to the budget but uh on page 138
to 151
it's a um refresh of the significance
and engagement policy and i'll leave
aleister to introduce there so that's
um so you may remember uh in i believe
it was late november i came and briefed
the council on the updates
to this policy there are no
huge material updates to it um i'm a
believer in that if it's you know not
broken it doesn't require being fixed
what i have done is i've expanded on
what's called the iap2
metric in that and that's an acronym for
the international association of public
participation
this is the engagement metric that's
used
um essentially uniformly across
central and local government departments
in new zealand and australia
and i've really just expanded on that
because through
avenues such as the mahitahi committee
we're starting to see
i guess more use of things like the
empowerment metric
but otherwise uh no significant changes
right okay
any questions did you want to answer
something just a very brief
addition look uh this is a this is a
statutory requirement to have a
significance and engagement policy
um uh we're the real
[Music]
value of this is the
guidance that it gives that comes from
it
and so the team is refreshing our
guidance across the organization and
in engagement we you know that we are an
engage you
we are an engaging organization and more
likely than not to be out in the
community
or be seeking the views of groups
but but some of the feedback is we're
quite uneven
in that in terms of
by by geographic area or by
by topic and we really want to cut more
underpin our quality of our engagement
with the community
so the guidance and the training then
roll out that goes with that
will be designed to do that and again
later this year you'll probably
you'll be having some more engagement
with alistair and the team around there
thank you um any questions
got a recommendation some of you to move
uh moved by council meetings taking a
bike out smoking some plus meetings
if you are can use your mic
not much to say except that um i really
commend your
commitment to continuous improvement and
all the work that you've done in this
space we have put you through your paces
this year with the things that have come
up
and you guys have worked hard and done
very well with it i do like the um
sorry the matrix um that
was the iap yeah yeah that really
simplifies things
and and um clarifies just what exactly
we're doing with regards to our
communication and that's really handy
too
um yeah really just keep up the good
work
and um i'll leave it at that
concert any further speakers
i'll put the recommendation unless you
wish to reply to yourself
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that gary all right
thanks alistair
so simon we've just got a further report
i think uh economic reduct uh economic
development
so what do we want to do why don't we
[Music]
um
help us
that's good i'm about to do it changing
the gap here
thanks marie welcome by the way thank
you
okay so um this year
um we've updated some of our revenue
figures
and um lim's income we've got a
substantial increase
because uh volumes
have done uh completely opposite than
what
we were told they would and we're
looking at
uh 238 000 income just till
the end of december this year so we've
upped that to
380 000 for the coming year
we have put the commission from
collection of ecam rates up to
about the level that we're paying or
receiving in the current year
we've got the rates discount expense
we've
adjusted that um more in line to what we
are
allowing now and discount and
i guess the key issue for me is the
request for another staff member
and our phone's team at rangiora
council approved the addition of a cadet
type role
last year that was left out when we
needed to
adjust the budgets and we're asking for
that position again
because the phone's team are really
under pressure
and we have been using casual staff
quite a lot during the busy periods
we're looking at a new phone system
that's more of a unified communication
system
so we're at the moment we've got um
the telephone calls coming into one
queue emails coming into an email box
they'll all be coming into the same
queue so it's going to be
a lot i guess more efficient and easier
to manage
and we feel that with that and an
additional staff member that
that will fix the issues we have with
staff
burning out during that sort of middle
of the year when everything happens
we're hoping that this role will appeal
to a young person because
there's a lot of opportunity for great
careers in local government
and it would be really good to be able
to get somebody in to start look at
what's available
hopefully do a few years in customer
services before moving
somewhere else and um yeah does it just
uh i guess balance the um the age
dynamic and the
and the team as well
[Music]
okay thank you marie
is there any questions of marie and the
budget papers there
no council duty marie when do you
propose to
perhaps bring this person on board
will be in july august
[Music]
that's when the budget's available
hopefully
okay any other questions of marie
um so we uh as i do at this point if
anyone wishes to answer anything in the
general comments
well thanks marie um you you and your
team do a great job and i know
we all work with you very closely with
dealing with some of our more trying
people at times
and one that i can't specifically talk
about it here but we did have a very
difficult circumstance which
through the work that you and your team
have done have turned that around
and that was really something i think um
you should be particularly proud of that
was
there'll be an opportunity to brief the
council at some stage about that but
um and even last week we had someone and
that was um
difficult to say the least um and
i think the way that that was handled
was was excellent because you're often
the front face of
things with custom when you are
front-faced with customer cfsa
thank you to what you and your team do
and i fully support the additional
resource so
thank you thank you thanks mr me i just
want to
note and commend the customer services
team
particularly during the covet period
haven't really had an opportunity to do
that
and just the
incredible way they divided themselves
into two teams
and maintained a really high level of
customer service
as best was as possible in really
exceptional circumstances and to some
extent that sort of translated into
current arrangements with an interim
customer services
desk at rangiora and a different
entrance and
all of that the actual and potential
disruption that that
presents and just briefly take the
opportunity to note that karen frieda
retires at the end of this year after a
very long record
sorry at the end of this week sorry
after a very long royal
and period of service to the waimakariri
district council in the community
so thank you would you say 25 years now
yeah it's been exciting 25 years i think
big sex
short of three months
thanks marie appreciate that um that's
your your budget's dealt with
so thank you oh sorry i mean
yes oh these i'm sorry serious too
uh rates remission policy so it's
um 11 um 4.9
yeah just recently yeah
just testing to see if your guys are
away
[Music]
you passed
it's two reports actually that's right
4.10 as well
so marie do you want to take us through
your reports
the first one is on
proposed changes to rates remissions
policy
that we discussed at a september
briefing
and the council indicated
a willingness to reduce
the interval at which people could
ask for rates penalty remissions
currently
it was four years or is four years and
we were accused of being stingy
and um the council was agreeable at that
time to reducing it
to two years and that put would put us
in line with most of the other councils
that we that we surveyed the other
uh the other one was on the policy for
remission of rates on
residential properties in um commercial
and business zones
where due to the the high ratio of land
value to capital value
those properties um end up paying quite
high
rates on land value at the moment that
really only impacts on the urban
drainage rates because that's the only
one that we've got left
on on land value but
it does they are quite out of kilter
with other residential properties so
it's definitely worth continuing with
this remission policy
but what we're asking is that it be
limited to those
owner occupied properties
within those zones and that we don't
include the properties that are used as
rental properties or the new
purpose-built
apartment type buildings
okay thanks marie any questions
counselor
you marie just how many houses would be
involved in that particular
how many dwellings would be involved in
that we only have nine
houses receiving the remission now and
it would reduce to four right okay okay
yeah my house apparently
still won't move out right
okay any further questions
moved to council atkinson segmented by
council duty do you wish to speak
to say that those that were stingy at
four years as opposed to two i clearly
don't know her accountant
so um thank you for the time
we've discussed tonight thank you for
the report it is good
okay and yeah i'd just like to say thank
you very much murray
it's been very helpful with you coming
and doing briefings for us because it's
keeping us
right up to date with everything and
this is just making
this plain sailing for us to go through
so thank you
okay any further speakers
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor of this ai
contrary to clearly carried then we're
now moving to 4.10
um which is tab 12 thanks murray
on the collection of actually water
rates
okay this um the actually
actually water rates on properties in
the waimakariri district
have historically been collected by the
purunu district council
and that just has been happening since
the amalgamation in 1989. it was part of
the reorganisation order that
the hironu council managed that water
scheme and
that since then they've been sending
rates assessments out to
rate payers in that northern part of the
district that are connected to the
scheme
that doesn't entirely fit within the
rating legislation
but it's worked quite successfully
we feel that it's probably time to
change that
so that we do comply if for example
somebody refused to pay
the heroinary rates they wouldn't be
able to
collect those through the courts because
it wouldn't legally be a rate a council
can't rate in somebody else's
district so we've talked about it for a
few years
and there's other advantages in this
council taking it over
one is that notices of sale when
properties change hands
all come to the scouts or they don't
necessarily go to hiranui as well
and even though we've got systems in
place where we
send them reports every month on what's
changed hands
they don't always get the information
and it's difficult for them to then
chase up overdue amounts when people
have moved on
so it's definitely a more streamlined
administration we'll work with them
because obviously
we're going to need to give them
information back on
who the property owners and contact
details are
so if there are issues with the water
supply they can
they can contact them quickly and make
sure that they get all the information
that
the other users of the scheme have we've
got a draft
memorandum of agreement with the hiranui
council
and that is going to be council as well
and we're just recommending that the
chief executive be
authorised to complete that agreement
with the hiranoi district council
thank you any questions counsellor
redmond sorry for the moment thank you
your worship
marie um when people people inquire
um lawyers in particular
about rights for apportionment
will under this new system will you
actually be able to answer that question
about the hiranui water rates or one
lake
so they won't have to compact haruni no
we'll be able to tell them what is
because they're on it they'll just be
another line on our rates assessment so
it'll be included in that
um we will probably still advise that
the property is on the hiranui water
supply because
you know there is going to be a
relationship needed between that
property owner and hiranoi
for the supply of water um at the moment
we do
tell tells the solicitors and the
inquiries that the property
is on that water supply but we don't
always have the up-to-date details about
the rates
the other thing with rates rebates is
that when people come in and they're
paying hiranui water rates
we have to include that on the rates
rebates that we do
and people don't always have that
information available
although we do try to have it here so
it's going to streamline that as well
so you would envisage only one notice of
sale
which would come to us
but there must be a mechanism for
notifying hironui
and that's what we're working on it's
going to be a two-way communication
we'll need to notify
haranui when properties change hands and
they'll need to notify us when water
units change or
new consumers come on boards so we'll
work out a two-way
communication so that each party is
getting the information
[Music]
yeah i actually support this so the
questions around
information that council reading was
just talking about but a little
different in the respect that if uh
decide they're going to have a 20 water
rate increase next year
um and we're showing the water the line
on
how we're going to do the communications
of sales you know because it looks like
buck passing when they come in our door
and go no no sorry not ask go and
submit to her and even though we're
charging
what's our um
scheme around dealing with that sort of
situation because that puts you guys in
a bit of an awkward
position it's a little bit like um what
we do with environment canterbury now
they they will tell us you know what
their rates increases are
and give us information so we can answer
basic questions and
if there is a 20 increase then there
should be
a reason for that and they would need to
consult with our
our rate payers in the same way that
they're doing that with
their own so our rate payers will be as
aware
as the hiranui people on what that
increase would be
[Music]
we can answer it to a certain level and
then when it gets too hot to handle we
can pass it on to
to the other council so so will it be a
separate
invoice within life of this with ekin
no no we we had a legal opinion
on this it's really only a
benefit to us if we can have it as a
line on our rights assessment because
if we have to start using a separate
ledger and having
an additional rates assessment and then
voice then
the economies or the benefits of of
doing it
um even though we probably still need to
do it because
it um it currently doesn't comply
the most efficient way of doing it in
the most cost effective way is having it
as a single line on our
rates assessment so that account will be
in this council's accounts and we'll
have an
expenditure item payment to haranui
district council
and so we'll collect the money on their
behalf and just pay it over
it's a wee bit different than what we're
doing with ecan and that they've got
their own separate ledger
they charge their you know penalties on
their rates which
go to them um with the hiranui rates we
will keep
the penalties and pay them the total
amount of the
rates strike each year and we will
keep the arrears and collect their res
and keep any penalties that are charged
it's probably no difference to what
we're doing now in effect
making it more open and disclosed
so most of the people that i've talked
to
that know about it that are on staff
have gone yay
will pay our rates through you so
basically we have no option to do it
anyway
because at the moment they could go to
the hirono registered council
and say well we're not paying this and
legally
they couldn't they couldn't charge them
so basically we just had to make sure
that we have an agreement
of what we're disclosing in both our
annual plans
to make sure it's quite clear that we're
collecting those rates on behalf
when when people are on their supply
they're pretty well
they pretty well know they're actually
on the hiranui water scheme
but they know there are actually wdc
ratepayers in effect so it's just making
sure that
if anything we're looking after our
ratepayers
and making sure we're disclosing the
full costs of them
exactly that around the cons of that
because if you
um they'll get there the rate demand
with the
with the new charge on it won't come
from hiranui automatically to a lot of
people that have been there for some
time will go oh good we've just gone to
the
wymax scheme so what are the comms
around
with these people that we're going to be
putting out there to let them know that
we are only exactly that the rates
collector and your scheme doesn't change
yeah our expectations if they're having
a large um increase
is that we'd um have an expectation that
they'd do separate consultation like we
would
i don't mean increases i'm talking about
they're going to get it they're going to
get their rates billed next year it's
going to have a line on it this
is rates for her annuity but where are
the comms to these people that that is
the change
because they're just going to assume
that they're
on the ymca scheme they've been changed
over and now that we will know that's
wrong but
yeah once once both of the councils have
agreed
to the change the hiranui district
council will be sending out
the initial communication to
to the consumers on the scheme
explaining
what is happening because we don't want
them thinking they're on the rank europe
and a waimakariri scheme because
um if there are any issues with the
scheme any outages
they need to communicate with her
annuities so they'll be making that
quite clear to them
so so when the rate saman goes out for
the year it could have
she do have capacity in there to perhaps
put a letter in explaining these
yes and and is there the ability on the
invoice to put
brackets something collected on behalf
of haranui district council
there's probably not room on the rates
but we could have something on the
we could have something on the back of
the notice
you just just so it's clear okay any
other questions
right we have a recommendation some of
[Music]
uh just to say it seems pretty logical
to me it was always a nightmare for
lawyers working out
uh what to a portion and it can be
easily overlooked if
you're not tipped off and you're not a
local um
it just creates a wee bit more
administration i suspect for you
and i might have to talk to colleagues
about why is it a hiranui water scheme
and not one of ours but
that's a separate issue
um speakers uh look how i'm gonna
support this i think it makes sense
um i think as long as there's a a good
letter that goes out
within the rates demand that explains
that clearly and then if there's ongoing
just so it is clear
some way of explaining that on the
invoice somewhere that would be
um really helpful because we've but
it's i kind of liken it to the fact that
if they were
they are our eight pairs if hirano we
weren't supplying the water we would be
uh in any event so it would be um
something that we would be doing
any when we've got a representative on
this water scheme and council williams
so that's
our accountability there and i guess
we'll get a heads up through there if
there's any major changes
one thing i was heartened with recently
was that hamish the ceo was saying to
both council williams and myself just
the large investment their rate powers
are
getting over there through the shop
already they're investing quite a lot of
money into
the upgrade of that scheme and upgrading
the quality
so we do have a very close relationship
with hiranui so
i'm not seeing a problem there we have
been talking about ikea
this morning and where they're hitting
and some of their rates and we do have
our concerns with that which we'll
address in our internal forums that
we've got but
um there's a concern if they're heading
in that level and we're collecting it so
that's probably marie where the
reservation's
coming from this morning because some of
their projections are looking fairly
interesting
and the accountability around that and
the bottom line
is the things that concern us i guess so
it's just the
reality of what people think when they
get that villain
and you'll know that from past
experience yourself
all right any further speakers write a
reply as williams
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor aye
contrary to clear that carried
all right so that's um
and this we're now up to um
development planning um so trevor
thanks marie
is
five nine five
[Music]
thanks trevor thank you one of the
papers was withdrawn
uh that when sarah emailed last night
that wasn't intended to be included in
the arizona yes it just said
it's all right thank you very much mr
mayor council
uh this um budget relates to the
development planning unit
i guess it primarily has a focus around
the district plan review at the stage
of proceedings uh the budget as
uh alastair alluded to is very much a
rollover budget
with the exception of a small amount
added for this financial year in the
next couple
relating to jes davidson and her
appointment as a
communications advisor and alice's team
uh we're using her
um on an equivalent of a couple of days
a week to get the comms plan sorted out
for district plan review
and that will have an ongoing function
over time as well
uh the significant uh change in budget
reflects
that that's already in the ltp for the
next year in the following year that's
around
commissioner costs which is not
insubstantial around
half a dozen commissioners who need to
hear the submissions on the district
plan
uh there's also some uncertainty as i've
alluded to in the narrative there just
around accommodation
costs we will need to come back to you
this calendar year
with some further information on that
and then there's the costs around expert
evidence to support submissions and just
the staff time as well
so it's not insurmountable but there was
no need to make any changes to that
budget that's already been approved
also just note in the narrative to
couple of extra matters which are
emerging
into this financial year
which relates to uh working on the
regional policy statement we've been
asked to contribute
to that in a working team environment
also
for those of you on the greater
christchurch partnership there's the
2050 work which is proceeding and we'll
continue to do so
and there'll be some staff time needed
on that that's still emerging as well as
to what the exact nature will be
and linked to the 2050 work is uh also
greater question spatial planning that's
just starting to kick off as well
and we're at the stages of starting to
think well what might this look like
what does it need to do how long will it
take
and how many bodies will it need to
evolve
from from council at the moment we're
slightly under resourced in that space
but
through myself or simon we'll certainly
be able to report back
in the course of this coming year around
the needs for that
so that's really just a quick um update
on on that budget and i'm not happy to
take any questions
great way the lights go out you got the
corporate credit card jeff
yeah that's quite nice
all right sorry with that excitement
was it it was illuminating and always
the one trevor
oh well done
yeah we we um we weren't trying to hide
any costs from you
we're trying to keep you there we'll
keep you in the dark
um just a very quick overall comment
um the district plan reviews as you know
are monumental undertakings
um and they've demanded a huge amount of
your time in the last year
and before that and the team's been
going on this for
to get to this point where this year we
can look forward to a notification
from a budgetary point of view for the
total project we're about half spent
but we are on budget for what was set
out
to set your expectations and our our
understanding
uh about three years ago where we're
tracking uh very close to that
and i just wanted to acknowledge the
teams
really concerted efforts and i know that
has been
reflected in district planning
regulation committee process but
it's extraordinarily difficult too with
these multi-year complex projects to
keep it
to get a team and keep them together and
get to the end and we are almost at the
end of the beginning
in terms of the notified draft
and there is a lot of process to go but
that
that becomes a little more out of out of
our control
but it also has a momentum that we have
to roll with
the team are going to be really
challenged because at exactly the same
time
as you the community and them
are working through trying to land this
as a as a operative district plan
over the next couple of years then the
whole planning framework at this point
in time
is is up in the air and some of you
might be thinking oh crikey why are we
doing all of this
if the game is going to change
completely
and it's a fair question that we've got
from the community as well
can i have assurance that this is going
to hold good
i put a lot of effort myself into this
and and we can't provide a lot of
assurance about that frankly
but we do need to continue to land this
review
uh just as quickly and as appropriately
as possible
it's not a criticism but it's a
commentary
the current operative plan was basically
developed in the late 1990s
it is 20 years old and it's been
an awful we've learned an awful lot
you've
experienced a lot of feedback from the
community about the strengths
and the weaknesses of the plan but it is
time to have
we don't know how it's all going to play
out but we do need to get
a contemporary district plan in place
and the team have
provided you i believe some really
excellent advice
to get us to that point thank you agreed
i'll see it simon um questions
thank you very much for that i'm just
really concerned about the workload that
you've got coming up with
not just with our district plan but
you've got all this other stuff coming
on board how are you going to manage all
that and
have you got the capacity and staff to
be doing all that
i guess that's the purpose of just
alluding to that in the in the
commentary for you it's really at the
beginnings of trying to understand what
the workload
in addition to the district plan will be
and i think we'll know more about that
in the first part
of this this calendar year as we work
through some of those uh sub-regional
and greater christchurch matters
um i suspect and i've certainly been
quite vocal with simon and others that i
think we will be under resourced
though we do need to sit down and think
about what our options are to best
progress not only the district plan at a
very very busy time but also those other
processes as well
we need to be in those other processes
in the regional policy statement
we need to be in the 2050 we need to be
in the boots or on the spatial planning
and we need to be there in a very much a
collaborative
proactive way rather than just reacting
and responding
um so look uh look we need just in the
short i i think we are
lightly staffed i think we all need more
staff we just need to marry that up
against how we progress with district
plan and other processes in terms of
some dives uh and humps and hollows a
little bit more thinking of doing that
and we'll certainly be back to you in
the due course on how to do that
i think we can give you at least a
progress report when you go into
deliberations in may
um we'll get a sense of where some of
those other
processes and requirements are
progressed over the next quarter or so
and
in a sense of the workload around
arising from submissions
we would hope by then or some sense of
how that's tracking
council my question was really but
that's i just don't want to see burn out
by the staff
[Music]
look like jim palmer if he was here and
jeff anyway and certainly if jim harland
were here
i know they would be saying look we will
be
closely monitoring uh workloads
across a number of fronts and you've
built today with utilities and roading
and all
of the parallel universe that they're
increasingly working in having to do
today's work
but but knowing perhaps more acutely
than anyone else in the organization
that that their organizational uh
framework for who they're going to be
working for
um in in in the medium term future
is decidedly uncertain at this point in
time
so as a management team
we've had a quite a lot of discussion
now about the change dynamic
that has has grown and been accelerated
because of covert
in many respects and there is a very
ambitious program of
government reform that we refer to
earlier
[Music]
that all that said sorry i'm going on
and i don't mean to but all that said
we have adopted the budget disciplines
that we
set out to do in october november last
year
and and all we can do from this point
forward is closely
look at how that tracks and keep you
well briefed as to where we get to and
we've gotta
we'll have a significant milestone uh
through the deliberations to alert you
to really
any significant changes that need to be
made and
and by that time jim harland will
have at least some time with the
organisation
under under his build
any further questions is there any
general comments
and some you summed it up really well
and when do your questions really act
around resourcing and
we'll welcome um there's the staff
submission process as well so
just keep us in the loop with how things
are going because it is really important
that we land it trevor thank you for
your leadership
um fantastic over the period a lot of
work
over these last number of years and we
were talking about some of it yesterday
and now about how we land our district
plan with our partners
which is going to be really important to
make sure that they
see the same vision that we do um so
that'll be the next part of our process
which is all about relationships really
when it comes to it
and and our community obviously so we'll
look forward to
their feedback and due course but thanks
for getting us to this point and kirsten
certainly um as the district plan leader
has done a really good job in keeping us
on track in the last year
it's been a hard task because there's
been so many meetings so
thanks um to kirsten for your lead there
all right thanks team
so we've landed your budget to date
um either that's right
so simon you can do your part now which
is economic development if you like and
um thanks
do you want to deal with the um report
first or do you want to deal with just
probably um
refer both thanks to the budget and the
report but just to
guide you the the actual
page could you go to page 606
oh sorry 60 601
601 and then on page 606
you'll see the economic development
budget and then
this is a game in two halves back at 577
you'll see the district promotions
budget
yep um so it's just kind of just
slightly hiccup at the number and the
ordering
uh i thought i'd lost district
promotions for a moment
[Laughter]
um
so um uh
back to 606 or the um so
you'll see that economic development is
um status quo
budget in the strictest sense
um it retains the principal cost there
is the
capacity grant to economic development
to interpersonal canterbury
uh under economic development um back on
built into that budget for district
promotions you'll see
there are other dollars there for the
capacity grants and the events
uh xmas event funding for the promotions
associations
and then the contract amount for enc and
that is reduced by 30
000 in line with the directives
for restraint last year now
my report now addresses that
reduction because that's a reduction in
an annual amount
over the next 10 years and if
we could go now to the
report and the agenda
uh sorry guys
so that's page section 4.8
page 284 to 291 and
um in that report
uh sorry i better go do it talk to it
so that's tab 10 yeah to have 10.
um so that relays to you
the response from the board of
enterprise north canterbury
um who as you can imagine weren't that
happy
with the idea of a sustained reduction
over the 10-year period
and i've set out and i i leave those
comments for you to consider i've not
tried to
comment on the board's comments
and i've set out in the recommendations
three options you can either
leave the budget as it is which is a net
reduction of 30 000 over the 10-year
period
or you can restore it or
i've suggested a course which you could
think of
as the middle option which is to fund
the next two years out of the covert
loan
and then restore the 30 000 for the
following eight years
and the thinking that i applied on that
option
was i don't think it now is the right
look we get it from the budget restraint
point of view
but i have to say from our economic
development agency's point of view
now is not the right time to be cut in
their budget
and and to be fair to them um
they have in the current year
reallocated on the fly an awful lot of
what they
ordinarily would have been doing to
covert
response and i think you'll all agree
they've
really stepped up in that regard so
i thought it was not unreasonable to try
and find the path of
respecting the desire for constraint
because you've imposed that
on a number of aspects of the
organization
and no one should be immune from that
but at the same time utilize the covert
funding capacity
that you do have to achieve that in the
next couple of years but then to revert
to the status quo
so thanks simon uh
you know once probably to jeff it won't
be just
i'm not sure but what we already passed
on the covert
or not past sitting there in the pro
forma do we we would need to change that
figure would we not
if we were to take the recommendation
is that you know the body where you
would take the two years because
your loan is just reinstated
yeah sixty thousand
apologies um draw that down
over the next 60 000 and fund enc
the 30 000 a year for the next two years
but and then revert this budget
to an additional 30 thousand uh funded
in the normal way
uh from the third year online i've got
no problem that that's fine i'm talking
about
what's sitting in the pro forma with the
with the fund um it's only got 700 000
out of it we're looking at reducing that
back
there just for our recommendation that's
what we're saying
so it does it does need a recommendation
to this right
to change what we did before but it's
sitting there in a great format could we
not just change the number on the pro
format when you've got when you adopt
this budget here you would just
all you do is take 30 000 for the next
few years from covert fund
and restore their 30 000 from year three
so or just as a recommendation i think
you could just recommendation f
is perhaps a bit cryptic but that's what
then was the intent
or you could just move a don't move b
c becomes um b
and then e becomes c and then leave f
and then it just
becomes a effectively it just puts it
back in as it was
rather than touching the economic that's
the other way of hearing it
and it just becomes a regular amount as
it was before
and it says it's inflation adjusted well
anyway that that'll be up to the movers
and second is
so kirsten um
just looking at 4.4
um can you show me the line where the
new visitor strategy implementation is
in the budget
[Music]
so we don't have a separate button
budget line item for visitor strategy
implementation
in a number of those recommendations
uh for enterprise north canada to
reflect in the district promotions plan
so when you get the district promotions
plan
sorry for the year that's the time when
you'll see the budget
implications of enc's efforts to
implement
the visitor strategy on the other side
of it
within our organization there are some
recommendations out of that for us
at the moment we are seeking to fund
that from within
our existing resources so we haven't
asked you for any additional funding at
this point in time
for that okay just to uh
council duties by council stuart thank
you
i'm just uh perhaps throwing a bit of
caution to the wind
um i'm just a little bit concerned about
taking
this money from the covert response
thing just for one year at the moment
we just don't know what's what's in
front of us and i'm just
feeling a little bit nervous about um
taking that money from that
thing just to just to top up for
put it's the second question yeah
so that's just my question on that one
oh oh
i'll answer your question with my view
which is um i think the benefit
for enterprise north canterbury the the
thing that they were struggling with is
as soon as you start tempering with you
know
wrong wrong turner phrase
but as soon as you start messing with
their budget you start messing with
fractions of people
and allocations and and
i think by restoring the 30 000 and i
personally believe it's a legitimate
thing to do out of covert
you're maintaining their capacity to
respond to covert
in the economic impacts so i think
that's a reasonable
that's a reasonable alignment thank you
councillor stuart
[Music]
that's right council stuart thank you um
i had a look back at some
enc's june 30th 2020 accounts
and in there they have 400 000 on
short-term investment
further 325 000 in cash
plus the last year's grant they are
holding 86 thousand dollars
in in reserve so they didn't spend
all of the grant we gave them
last year i've noted this now to
take to the next time they come back but
can anyone
ask answer why they didn't spend
all the grant they got last year and
silently either simon or yourself
as a trustee so i haven't got a detailed
breakdown in front of me of that
of that underspin but an element of it
that i'm
i'm aware of is that um events
last year were obviously
hugely uh suppressed and
um so there is an element of carry
forward of
the events fund um that is and
and that has built up um as well
and one of the one of the dilemmas about
events on a contestable basis is you
want them readily available
and and we give large numbers of
organizations
relatively small amounts but not all of
them over time
get spent and some of them get allocated
and you're
looking and they're telling you that
sorry they're
giving you too much of detail perhaps
but but giving
saying we'll do it and then they don't
do it this year and then they do it the
next year and they hold the money so the
reality is that enc at any one time
has quite a bit of event funding um
i'll call it there available
unspent and then of course no one was
doing events
particularly last year for a period so
there's quite a bit
the other underspends on elements i'm
not
familiar enough right here and now with
the accounts but that's something for
you to ask enterprise north canterbury
i think when they uh furnish their um
accountability documents if jim was here
he'd be able to give a bit more of a
fuller answer
he's also an advi comes as an advisory
trustee there but
enterprise north canterbury have also
invested in
made in north made in north canterbury
they provided support and accounting
advice
to a number of organizations which they
took out of reserves
same with madden north canterbury wow
was another one that they took from
reserves without with this council's
blessing
so it might show that sandra but
actually
in actual fact the cash positions i've
been a bit nervous about that
as we've been going forward and asked
those questions
because there's been a range of
initiatives to support our community
in our business community particularly
in a difficult time
and those reserves have certainly not
been what they may have been presented
at that time but they'll be able to
provide further clarity on that
as a trustee i'm aware of just those
particular matters
that have been considered by the board i
think i just wondered whether um
mr millwood wanted to comment on on
the fact that there is they carry so
much in
short-term investment i mean how would
you regard this organisation to be able
to
stand a 30 000 a permanent
thirty thousand reduction in the grant
that the
council um provides to it
uh for their accounts they're definitely
cash rich
both their current liabilities are way
out low
uh way their current liabilities
so you've got in my estimation about 350
customs in the bank they definitely have
86 000 from the council which they
didn't spend last year
um they haven't spent it we should be
asking them what haven't they spent it
on
uh they're a taxable entity uh the
reason they put their a6000
aside is generally because they've got
liabilities which they can justify
we just have to get an understanding of
what those liabilities are that they
haven't actually spent
money on so they're in a good position
um
but it's it's i suppose what we're
talking about here is
i don't know thirty thousand dollars
it's neither here or there it's about
uh what what's our overall
uh strategy and support of an
organisation that provides economic
development
district i think what i'm hearing at the
moment is we need to sustain that sort
of
investment to make sure that it's uh
a viable business and it's um it's
meeting those measures that we've put in
the statement of intent
but certainly when the statement intent
comes through i think we should
challenge that
and ask you know why wasn't the a6000
spent and
what was it supposed to spend okay
thanks jeff
um did you have a question council award
okay
we'll just can we just wait a second
i'll just check if there's any other
questions council williams
my question is should we not then wait
until they
need this money before we may
[Music]
bring it up and organize it for them
because at this stage obviously they
don't need it
and um
so should we just should we just put
this amount on hold for another
year or two years until they actually
come up and actually need it and show us
what they can spend it on
um a couple of comments i'm
i'm not fully informed to comment on
enc's needs
i would say as a as a not-for-profit
organization
who's got a major contract about to end
on the 30th of june which is the
contract with the council
and the council needs to decide whether
it wants to renew its district
promotions contract
if i were on their board i'd be
concerned about
my cash reserves because if i've got it
then
if that contract isn't renewed then i've
got redundancies
uh as a board to consider so at this
point in time
uh until that contract is renewed and
they've got no certainty at this point
at this point um then um
i would be concerned about my reserves
now i'm on another board at this point
time with exactly the same issue so
that's the response that we're taking
in relation to that in question
that doesn't really my question i don't
see it
well thank you i think it was answered
well it's my decision whether it was
answered not an idea it was so
um if you have a supplementary question
you're welcome to answer it
i think i think it was addressed um
simon just wanted to ask just under
expenditure with the page
577 it's got the grants to
um events for the christmas
events i think they are um
under expenditure kit between now
and um our consideration i was wondering
if you could
ask vanessa or and simon if they could
check with the
event organizers whether those grants
are adequate
because my understanding is particularly
in oxford
the cost of the um
traffic traffic management is such that
it's making that
fairly marginal so just want to check
that those sums are correct if you
wouldn't mind
the team to look into that that would be
appreciated
thank you all right so i've
need further questions councillor
redmond you'll
confess the meeting with a
recommendation yes thank you mr mayor
i'd like to remove recommendation
a c and e
[Music]
a c and e okay
which can be re-lettered if you wish but
in terms of the recommendation
someone prepared a second
um i might need council award given
she's a portfolio holder if that's okay
all right counselor redmond
thank you mr mayor i think we've asked
enc
can they trim their budget their
activities by thirty thousand dollars
and they've come back and said well what
would you like us to leave out
which is a legitimate response i think
in the current climate
covered and unknown
as we move into the future enc
other people with their business
development
that we actually want to be supporting
and
i've found them very useful over the
past year if i have inquiries i quite
often refer people to
enc for advice and assistance
and i've been quite impressed with the
role they took on
over coven and i think we're sending the
wrong message if we try and reduce their
budget
they may have cash reserves i don't know
the purpose of those but that's
something we can ask them about when
they come along to see us in the next
month or two
so i'm very much supportive of the work
they're doing and i think we should
encourage them
the response and comments i could sense
a feeling of disappointment
um when i read their board comments
um and i i think we should be
encouraging
and not discouraging them thank you
thank you council what do you wish to
speak
[Music]
i'm very much in favour of keeping
um and not reducing by 30
000 i would have preferred probably to
get that extra money in this instance
from the covert recovery loan for the
next two years
reverting to ordinary funding after that
i think it's really important that we
that we we keep them at you know
at their rate because i happen to know
that the monies that we give them pays
their basic salaries for their
for their people so that they can
perform if we cut back 30 000 a year
then they would be looking at reducing
these staff ratios and
and someone would be without a part-time
job and i think we would be
we would be giving them doing them a
really huge disservice
and knocking them back we don't we can't
underestimate
how much value they add to economic
development
and the promotion of our region by you
know i know that
heather spends all her time going out
and raising independent funds
you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars a year
they raise independently which we
couldn't do
through the council and they work very
very hard
and we need them more than ever coming
out of covert we need them as we recover
from
covert and we really really need
all of their expertise and um
they're very frugal and the fact that
they've got money put aside
they go they need that as a backup
because you don't know what's around the
corner they may need it
for wheels over white pro or
wow somewhere along the line they're
going to use it
um to the benefit of our district and i
really
think that it gets my support to
to keep to keep that 30 000 per annum
there
but um whether we do it in e or if
um i i think possibly
um that's for us to decide but we
certainly need to do that
thank you councilman do you wish to
speak
oh you indicated you were willing no i
come to councillor atkinson first
that's fine uh council reckinson thank
you
look i am supportive of this um
if there were not cash reserves held by
this organisation we'd be sitting there
saying
are these people viable for the next
couple of years should we invest
in in someone that's running a business
that doesn't have cash reserves and
backstops because we would
we wouldn't be we would be saying this
organizers and running the organization
isn't running
properly yes you could argue that now is
the time to spend
cash reserves you could of course you
could argue that
and i think it's a bit rich to think
that um
a carryover of 86 000
for stuff some stuff that's actually
going to be committed already and will
be
and and the balance of that as a
carryover when a council of ours
um need i remind people of the carryover
figure that we have
and the explanations that we have around
that carryover
over figure i think that uh just simon's
very basic um explanation of the
carryover
puts it in perspective and uh it'd be
pretty rich of this council to
uh to knock it back on on those
on the basis of a carry-over that's
that's going to be needed in the future
because
believe me once level one does go and it
may not be this year
um there will be events have a look at
the events that are out there now and
how
well they are attended because there
hasn't been any and there will be more
and more people looking for money in
which to run those events
speaking where i've got um myself
council stuart there williams so i i'm
fully in support of this uh it's
if we took and it was a very brave
discussion at the board that was led by
um was taken there and asked and you've
seen the results that came back in terms
of the
commentary there and what impact that
would have this is the very time
as councillor atkinson rightly observed
saying prior to that council award
being mentioned by
councillor redmond as well it's a really
important time
um there's a number of events they're
looking to establish here
thirty thousand dollars per annum
actually can make a great deal of
difference if we take thirty thousand
dollars away
it will have a direct consequences of
event funding not being available
to particularly new events that are
coming here i just
you know i'm aware that we're just not
far away from
getting the motor caravan association
over the line and
cardboard which is this i wasn't sure
whether you'd hit it or not
but also last week motor caravan is
another um
entity within the motor caravan
association they're looking at doing a
national event
uh in kaiapoi so the other particular
and they're bringing you know hundreds
of people here
um and the potential of attracting more
the two events that the last weekend
muscle car madness and the new wheels
wings and wheels or whatever they called
it an oxford fantastic event
uh that's got so much potential um
there's there's lots of events that are
being thought of
so that's the other sort of groups that
may be
be deprived or new opportunities that
may be provided
deprived when our new stadium is
is available and there are lots of
things being thought of
that could go within the indoor complex
that just just haven't been thought of
before i think it's very prudent
position of the board to have a cash
reserve they
they only when heather and the chair
come here
they can explain that and how that's
made up
to all of you at that point this
organisation
has been reviewed agnosium by this
council
um they deliver they really do deliver
and through the um the time of the
of covert in particular they said this
immediately got set up to
support our businesses here and
providing them with key
financial advice which to be honest
saved a number of entities
a number of people that contacted me and
i was able to refer them to
enc and they got some positive advice
because people were really desperate
as we know through that time didn't know
whether they were going to have a
business
uh on the other side of covert and we
are in a really risky situation i don't
want to see
us take personally take money out of the
covert
budget at this point i think counselor
written is absolutely right
it should be properly funded and being
returned to the level it was before
so i just urge you all to support it enc
will come here and report as they always
do
um and we can ask them the questions and
be satisfied one way or the other uh
on those but this is an organization
that we do need
it's really important that we fund them
properly
in their delivery for our district and
getting events here and all the other
business support
they provide okay so
council stuart followed by council lands
thank you mr mayor i won't support
the granting of the 30 000
i think it is very timely as we've asked
every other department
within this organisation to
thoroughly review its budget um in this
covet environment and we have had that
and we're looking at what is probably
going to be one
of the lowest if not the lowest rate
increases of a
council within new zealand um this
organization
is extremely cash rich
400 000 on short-term investment which
is earning
interest on the money is accrued
from our grant money i would say with
quite a lot of certainty because in fact
the project money that enc is able to
get by going out and
asking for funding for a service that
delivers to the community
is totally specific to that project
it wouldn't be able to bank
bank that and and get um short term
interest plus it's got a further 325
000 in cash and other investments
in addition to the 86 000 of unspent
grant
from last year i don't dispute that
economic development and promotion of
the district
is um is a valid function
for the for this council it's absolutely
a no-brainer
but what i do dispute is in fact we have
a cco
that that undertakes that function
and as a cco it has extra costs
it pays an external accountant to do its
books
it brings in a
an administrator an external
administration which it pays
and our other cco which is to itara
trust
gets that service from this
council so as i said i i think it's
timely and indeed we need to ask
questions of of enc when they next
appear and i consider myself remiss and
not
identifying that it's extremely
rich position when in fact we
we need to sort of looked asking
questions earlier and we should have
reviewed when in fact that grant money
is being well spent as i said don't
confuse that
with the function they carry out i am
thoroughly in support of
that function it's just the entity that
we use
to get that function done in our
community i do have
difficulties with and always have been
and as i said in this instance
we are asking every other section of
this council
to take a cut and review its budgets
that's been done here and of course are
we surprised
no we can't in fact look hard at those
accounts
and they have got money in there that
they should
actually dip into at this point so no
i won't support that in fact we
let the status quo go pass and i think
as a council
we are remiss if we don't ask them to
take a small cut so thank you
thank you council stuart question would
you say well my question is probably to
you as a trustee really
um is it not
ordered new zealand just the information
there i'm just want to make sure it's
not misleading
is the audit that's done is done by
audit new zealand
and is required by a statement of intent
is that not
is is is that not the case that is a
requirement it's not a
something they do as an extra expense
that's that's a requirement for our soi
is it not
that's my understanding thank you it's a
requirement local government act
the cco's
okay all right
okay um thank you councilman
yeah um whilst originally i wasn't a
great supporter of enterprise north
canterbury lately
i think they have been doing a real good
wonderful job
however it's a want
money not a need money and at the moment
there's other organizations and other
council projects probably more in need
of money
and that's why i'd like to see and wait
until actually
need the money for a project because
they are cash rich
they're richer than this council to a
degree they've got money in the bank no
overdraft
we've got borrowed money so i don't
think would do justice to the rate cars
by giving excess money away at this
stage
until they actually need it for our
project to show us that they need it
and then i would support them
full-heartedly but
at this stage i haven't been
shown one iota that they've got any need
for this money at the moment
i've asked the question there's nobody
come up
in this room here that they need it all
they do
is want it to accumulate on top of the
existing funds they've got
so i i would i would 100
support it if i was shown the facts that
they need the money because i think
they're doing a really good job
order please counseling entitlement so
as i say
if i could be shown they need the money
i'll 100
percent uh you know push for it but at
this stage i have not seen that and i
think the rate cars
deserve particularly in these times for
us to hold back and be more
frivolously with their money than what
we
have been doing for this particular one
just to clarify cash rich cash rich
400 000 if you look at it in terms of
the turnover
which i think is around about two
million dollars now
uh 400 000 would fund 25 percent of the
year so it only funds three months
of the year so um it
really does rely on the council funding
uh the activity and i sort of reiterate
again
it goes back to the statement of intent
that the council actually
adopts each year within it agrees on
those levels of performance
and that's what we're really sort of
talking about at the moment is what is
that
level of performance that you want to
actually
nc to perform next year uh and i think
once again that 30 000 is is uh sort of
a provision for the defense funding to
sort of spur things along
so cash rich has a lot of meanings but
when you look at it in terms of the
turnover
doing the statement of intent that we're
requiring them to do it it's only going
to fund the next three minutes
it's reply to that on my question or
statement there as i was stating if they
come up to me
and prove that they need that money for
link it's a different kind of fish
okay major point thank you williams
account do you wish to speak counsel
i just want to remind everyone what
we're here for today because we're not
here
to get a report from enc we're here to
do a draft
budget and it's only a draft so this is
what we think is our best bet
going forward to put out the
consultation to the community
so we have to make a call here today
whether we think
this amount is the right amount that we
should be putting out to the community
we're not here to debate enc's budget
we're not here to say
whether they've got money or not we're
not here to say whether they're cash
rich or kespo
enc is a not for basically not for
profit they aim to make zero dollars but
they do have money in the bank
because otherwise they couldn't operate
what we're taking here from them if i
look at the budget line
isn't necessarily from the events
funding it's actually could well be from
someone's job
so you're actually reducing someone's
hours um
which it's not not our call it's their
call because they take this money and
they spend it how they see
fit but the actual events funding line
looks like it's
there's a 50 000 for that the 30 000 may
well be in that but i'm not here to look
at that detail today
all i'm looking at today is what money
we should put in our draft
budget that's prudent i don't think
reducing
the district promotion budget i don't
care who runs it
today is a good idea so i'm happy to
leave it
with the existing budget provision that
we've got going forward and i'll tell
you why
when you run a business and economic
activity is going down and it's under
threat
it's the time you actually spend more on
promotion you spend more on advertising
it's not when things are going
swimmingly you don't have to advertise
but when things are under threat
and the economic activity is under
threat you need to promote
more and with the district tourism that
we see that the
national tourism coming up is a big
thing at the moment we need to grab our
share of the pie and that was quite
clear through the visitor strategy which
you've all received a copy of
so now is not the time to cut promotion
budget
um the covert thing i think that's
window dressing
i don't actually think it's this we can
necessarily attribute 30 000 to covet
i think actually they did divert a lot
of their event resource
into business support during the covert
period so the people who would have been
working on
promoting us actually were diverted into
looking after the businesses
so in that way you could easily say it
was probably more than thirty thousand
dollars it was taken away from promotion
and put into business support during
that time
so i understand the covert argument but
i think that's window dressing we're
looking at a budget going forward
so this is uh do we want a promotion
budget going forward
um i want to listen to the submissions
but i want to put it out there at a rate
that we
think is appropriate our district
promotion budget is really low
for a district of our size it's it's
terribly low other districts have much
higher
promotion and economic development
budgets but we rely on enc to
use this money to leverage lots of other
money from other places
and every year we debate this budget um
which is
it's always going to be debated as is it
a nice to have but to me
it brings money into the district and it
was a point councillor atkinson
made when i debated the park and ride
but i'd forgotten um when you have a
facility or an event that brings
people into the district those people
spend money
they spend money in businesses they
spend money at activities
and they bring people and activity into
our district they actually provide
economic activity and if we reduce our
promotions budget
we are at a risk of actually reducing
our economic activity
so i'm 100 um supportive of keeping it
at the status quo if anything we should
be increasing it
but we can't quite afford that so
keeping it at the status quo i think is
a sensible thing to do
and we can review enc's budget when they
come and present it to us we've got that
information in front of us
thanks casabata uh kassadin
very much i just um was reflecting back
and um you know enterprise north
canterbury have always
run the business awards and i think that
this last year
they were supposed to have been run in
which they cancelled
so that's quite a sizeable amount of
money that they would have
normally spent on our businesses so i
i don't have any problem with supporting
the
promotional things at all
followed by council are you indicating
as well yeah just my two
very brief two things with council
voting is quite right this is draft
consultation and we'll wait and see what
people have to say and i did notice a
330 per person earlier paying 416 per
person
um but anyway we'll hear back from the
persons
thanks uh
this is a solvent organization doing
good work that we need them to do in a
time when we need them to do it and i'm
perfectly
um happy with giving them the money to
do so
any other speakers accounts of the
redmond jewish dude says rather reply
uh just briefly mr mayor i may be
standing in the way of an exit
no because i'm no i'm trying to get
through some other things if we can
there's more business well i agree with
your comments that this is an
organisation that does deliver economic
development
and promotion for the district
i think the question of reserves and
their
solvent status is a red hearing it's
really nothing to do with what we're
discussing today
i also note that in the board comments
they made reference to the fact they
didn't have a cpi
increase which cost them fourteen
thousand dollars
um so they've already exercised some
restraint
and i'm reminded of a bank manager um
who asked for the umbrella back when it
rains
so i'm not going to be the bank manager
asking for the umbrella so i
i support the thirty thousand dollar
increase okay thank you
thank you i'm going to put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear do you wish your vote
reported so
i declare that carrie so it was
counsellor
williams and stewart
okay so um
thank you simon i think that's i think
that's i think that's
that's it mr mayor just one very quick
comment just to note
that there is some change in reporting
lines
take effect from monday next week from
my point of view so
jeff millwood becomes takes takes
oversight with marie of customer
services
liz smith takes uh communications and
engagement
and uh in due course when tracy cheney
is
on wood she'll take on development
planning unit
according to this this year she's coming
tomorrow so i see that
i see that jim early i won't tell you
what he said back to me but
um um tracy won't be fronting tomorrow
but um thanks simon for
uh your work in those particular
portfolio areas you'll
you'll be of course we we know you're
continuing but
we appreciate the lead that you've been
playing in that space so thank you
council i'd just like to say a big thank
you to simon
and i'm all the best when you go to
wellington um to local government and
you
give them heaps they let them know how
we're feeling and how
what we're doing and don't let them away
with anything please
there you are you've got you've got a
big broad rim out there simon
see what you bring back
all right okay so we're going to
continue um because
we are scheduled to finish at six but it
would be quite nice to
complete some other areas if we can so
jeff if we could
if you already could we do finance a day
which
is 607 to 613
607 to 613.
i'll just see whether um paul
christensen comes
across so um
so basically uh the caring museum
basically the commentary has been read
there's a recommendation there which
is separate to the others which
request the counsel to agree to that
h61 forecast
yeah the consultation period so they'll
need to
request us to approve that and in
like other years they've also requested
a date to come and present to the
council via
the canterbury museum plan
[Music]
it's a date um i'm still not sure
whether they've got
the dedicated funding from the
government to fund that
portion so pretty much
in status quo for over years i know that
the
lodging resource consents and trying to
push that side of it along
uh utilizing the canterbury funds
themselves that they've got on hand
but basically there's a an intention or
as well as more like a promise actually
to try and
keep the project to the 195.2 million
and that's what they've presented in the
current draft plan
and that's been circulated to council
so basically um any questions
any
average rate that we've gone from thirty
dollars a year uh thirty one dollars a
year to thirty dollars a year right
through the years there's a reason we've
dropped a dollar per rate power i mean
that's on the mythical average but
for any reason given the light of what's
happening the reduction of a dollar a
year just
won't make a material difference but it
will do overall
that's probably uh something i've done
when i've
put the rates across
no this we could keep that rate uh
exactly the same it's just that we're
not passing the fund
across the development levy we're
holding so we're just building a fund
for when that happens
when it happens we'll we'll pass it
across in three
over three years which is supposed to
start in 20 to
23. uh so um
[Music]
we could put that back up to a dollar if
you like it makes difference
in light of things i mean it's a
question for the table not for me i
would suggest that
you know it makes a marginal difference
but it's still another dollar per year
that people don't have to find that's
all
[Music]
catherine
jeff i think there was a question over
the
museum board's ability to levy
a capital uh component
and i seem to think that may have been
the subject of the legal opinion
or something did anything come from that
no i couldn't find the legal opinion on
it
in terms of the capital levy it all
referred to the basis of
charging an operating levy
and i went to the museum themselves to
see if they had
legal opinion on that which they didn't
and
um nigel who's their cfo
referred back to the operating levy
basically
they could raise a loan and charge an
operating levy
which funds the operations of that loan
and so that's the
cash 22 that you have effectively
um uh
i i think if it got challenged legal
opinion would be that
we would be funding the operations of
the of the museum
you know if the council were of the uh
opinion they wanted to challenge that
then we could get that legal opinion
[Music]
uh
would they have their ability to raise
their top money
uh as an operating expense
uh i believe they would be able to
they would effectively
[Music]
be referring their security to our rates
and libbies and i suggest if they went
out there for
a credit rating they'd give you quite a
good rating
now the question is i noticed i've got
24 25 10 percent increase 10 percent 20
next year 10 percent the next year
that's correct massive massive increases
so
should we be going back to them and try
to rain them in and say look
our projected take is not
on equal footing is what they they are
doing
um very hard to justify a 10
increase year after year after year
yeah i've signaled that
for probably about the last at least i
remember about last
must be nearly 10 years now uh and the
basis of that is the
investment of the 195 million
they'll have a much substantial more
studies building
a larger area probably larger staff
and so that's what's making up that
those huge increases
their intention is to rate for the
levy asked for the additional
depreciation
which they are trying to progressively
fund
over a period of time to get it to the
true operating costs
so that in future years they wouldn't be
coming back to the council to fund their
capital
works they would be accumulating funds
themselves
so should we put a sort of submission
out to our rate cars and ask them if
that is what our ratepayers want to
fund
[Music]
i'd like to see a result on something
like that
[Music]
that's that's the decision of the
council of um i think
we we generally put that in the um
the annual plan we don't really bring
specific notice to it
we have in the past and we have a few
that have submitted against it but
generally
taken silence as an agreement that they
are acceptable to it
[Music]
okay any other questions
the status quo position is what's here
so
i hear what counselor williams is stated
but i i don't personally wish to go
through
an exercise right at the moment on it
it's we're required by law
we're involved in conversa just we're
involved in conversation with other
mayors
and other councils around putting
putting them on discretionary around the
195 million
they're going through resource consent
exercise at the moment because they have
to
uh well they need to in which to acquire
funding from outside sources
and they've got a mammoth task to get
the crown on board so
we don't know anymore at this point but
it's prudent for us to be putting aside
because we know
some stage will get called upon in which
to make the contribution which we're
required to by
an act of parliament and there's no
desire to change that
from from any side of politics at this
particular
point in time so uh from what we've been
advised so
i think it's prudent that we carry on
the course that we have look i don't
like it
we've all been through this exercise i
don't like it anymore than the rest of
us do but
it's it's just it's fruitless wasting a
lot of effort on it
so what's the requirement of us um
passing this in their budgets what
happens we voted against this in their
budget what's the
what's the predicament where would that
put us
there's a there's a process that you
have to go through and generally
um we could we could
object to the levy
and when we usually we were objected to
levy the
the canterbury museum we've called a
special meeting
to hear the objection um
basically you would need to get a
majority of the other contributing
authorities
no other words you know to set the rate
the same as what it was in the current
year
but basically you would need hironui
selwyn ourselves to object to achieve
that
or christchurch city and ourselves
basically christchurch city have
required
the museum to try and keep the increase
this year i think it was two or three
percent
which they've achieved and so
they would be happy with that because
the museum have met that um
that goal they are the major contributor
and so
we don't we're done unlikely to have a
successful result
okay all right thank you thanks
jeff um so we're now at 607
so we've got page 607 it's the finance
and aim
budget so that's jfan paul you have just
no because we've already moved at pro
forma yeah so
unless there's an amendment it stays um
and i was test looking around and
everyone seemed happy so well
well you know understanding of where
we're at
accepting uh paul thank you
thank you um the finance aim budget
um has been prepared very much on a
business as usual
basis we've made no changes to ftes or
significant changes to
service levels as such it's
there's no signaling changes
in spending or breaking or
funding impact
okay thank you thanks paul any questions
at full
no it doesn't appear so so oh hold on
sorry council award
question is don't you think you've done
well
well i think i actually think that's
probably something we can comment on
collectively and say thanks to jeff and
paul
and the amazing finance team we have you
know all the work that goes in as
a means of thank you it's a council
award you may wish to
you can join in that remark if you wish
but i don't um
paul you've done a fantastic job really
here i know and
um well dan you and i've been on the
long term plan but but you know we we do
understand
the pressures that we put on the finance
for jeff and paul and the team and
and i've seen the stress in your face in
december
and i hope that you're feeling a bit
better now but um i think you've all
done an amazing job and keeping things
done
to um to to to our wishes
well done and we really really
appreciate you
um thank you i'll pass that on to my
team who've now in our very
very experienced team and um i'm
i'm fortunate to be able to rely on them
to do really good work
i remember when the local government new
zealand
ratings come out and had the finance
result here
paul's um i think he gave the team a
shout
and i don't think we go we couldn't get
off the ceiling for quite a while
yeah well that was
and and we're all so so proud of that
you know that rating
whenever we go to local government
forums we're all told about any standard
and pause as well
it's just something that we are very
proud of so thank you for
all the work that you and your team do
to get to keep us at that point and
make sure that we're well advised
financially so thank you
all right that's it thank you
all right so um
become jeff we might do the water unit
now and then we'll come to governance so
that's
six thirty to six thirty five
look at the head sarah say
now i've said that damn it
uh yes the audience is much like the
project delivery unit the pdu it's an
internal service delivery
unit and it has a reticulation and
treatment teams that work on behalf of
our cost unit controller
we have a service level agreement
between
jared's team and my team to
deliver the service
you can see at the moment we're out for
a water unit manager
and that's this time it's been done
through brennan's
so yeah basically
most of its turnover years it works out
around about
70 percent as operational work just
responding to service requests
breaks making sure the treatment
stations are all
um topped up i've had some
uh fun and games with view hill
over the last few weeks trying to find
leaks um but basically
uh now it's 30 is capital works which uh
we tend to keep around under 250
000 the rest of it is actually tended
out
so yeah happy to take any questions um
i think the major bit of piece of work
this year is
getting an additional portacom there
health and safety we want to
the purpose of that is we want to
do more training keep the competency
rates up uh particularly if the unit is
absorbed into a new industry to make
sure that staff is
uh in the best possible position to
actually
at least retain its the type of work
they're doing or
have an opportunity promoting themselves
in a new organization
in the next year we're looking at taking
on two
apprentices at the start of the year and
two apprentices at the end of the year
and that room would be used as a
training room for those apprentices and
the average age of the water unit staff
is starting to get on and so we
through attrition so as two come on two
will probably go off
and um yeah it's just a matter of
keeping that team
uh fully um
um in your own capacity to do the work
uh
it's an interesting
it's been interesting actually managing
over the top of the team over the years
it's difficult to find the skill set
in the private market
and so you tend to um
attract people from other centres to
come and work for us
and they do tend to come from the
smaller organization you know smaller
councils and then
uh work themselves into the teams which
in lots of ways it's the detriment of
those other small councils because
they find it difficult to attract staff
too
um i can talk about this all day
it's the same with our rating staff our
reiki staff are difficult
but basically you're happy taking
questions thanks jen
any questions so council atkinson
uh when
you've got noted in here and in your
highlights the the vehicle
changes are they um because of growth
and need
and extra vehicles and if they're not
why are they actually highlighted not as
a business as usual
changeover or rollover if you like or
are they
a lot more expensive than we we have
budgeted for why
are they a highlight in here when i
would have thought that it's an
operational cost
that would already be in your budgets
and just before i've
finished look congratulations it's very
exciting
to think that councils are looking at
apprentices i think that is
absolutely fantastic it is back to the
old days i know but it is
absolutely fantastic that you're doing
that
so yeah no reason why they're
highlighted they are replacement
vehicles
but um we're looking at trying to get
something that's a bit more
um multi-skilled to
do the work and that's carrying the
equipment as well as
you know being used for other tasks as
well so i'm trying to look at the
look at them we tend to um
quite often we do tend to buy secondhand
in this in this
area we don't buy brand new yeah because
of the
some of the value of the vehicles are
quite high so
um but we we look at the market and see
which is the best
uh buy and we double check that with um
the best car which is as oversees our
purchases
[Music]
yeah it's not a big amount but traffic
management equipment
you know six thousand dollars every year
i would imagine once you buy cones
and some traffic um signs and bits and
pieces
they last quite a long period of time
so what was it kind of valuing them for
but you know cones only get pinched
every now and then um yeah
i'm not sure i think it is wear and tear
it's a wear and tear cost
um no it's not cheap for the health and
safety equipment
and um but i'll double check on that
other traffic management equipment
it's the cones and everything that's
there i know i know
i i went and flogged some cones when we
had covered
and forgot to return them back and got
taught off of that but
i think it is wear and tear
all right thank you uh council council
duty did you
question okay
just checking council becky
um
halfway down the page six three four um
stop taking why has that gone up
to about 30 percent in one jump was it
too low before and then it stays at that
level forever as that was it too low
before
um
[Music]
i'm trying to think of a good answer
yeah
i yeah i
i'm not sure i'll have to double check
but i um
overcovered what we are finding that's
actually
um so i've required the stock taking so
there might be a lot of staff time as
well
doing the stock taken in terms of
downtime
um so i've required them to do at least
four stock takes this year
generally they get too done the sound is
very very small but they need to do more
and the other thing i've asked them to
do is keep the stock levels
about 25 higher than what they normally
do
uh but you'll find a lot of that type
that that there is more time
than the actual um you know loss of
stock and uh pilferage and stuff like
that
uh it is something that we've talked
about um
trying to do more regular stock takes
before was here quality off to answer
that one because
um they work with the order unit to
um to do the stock tank and it
does take quite a bit of time because we
have stock on trucks
three different areas and then we have
the main stock area
we also have a stock person
who's basically
sort of half seemingly retired that used
to be one articulation workers
and
[Music]
uh without no no it's a dark stevie
stevenson
and that would be some of his time as
well
okay council did you hear a question
this time
oh you put your hand up
oh okay all right waving back
yes
any further questions because just for
cured what
document in terms of dollars or
in terms of dollars compared with what
cost of doing some of the stock takes
effect uh they they they seem to
move between about 95 and a hundred and
sixty five thousand of
true value of stock and um
your right the right offs and right ons
will
go between two thousand and about ten
thousand what i'm getting is costing us
forty five thousand
dollars to stop take nike yeah five
thousand dollars of the stock
yeah we
we've pulled the stock take right right
back over the years and we tend to use
the suppliers
as our stock holding
bins so you know like a weight fuel type
thing and we try and
do it through purchase orders and
as we require it but yeah yeah
it's a fair call yeah okay
you know part of that 45 000 you i mean
you talk about you
your stock taker but would then does
that include a storm and someone who's
actually checking stuff in and out as
well so there's actually part-time wage
in there
for that sort of thing as well as a
stock destroyer
it is i suppose i should add to it as
well probably the turnover our stock is
the key thing
um what actually goes through the
boarding is is probably more like
um half a million dollars so that's
that's different again so this is only
what we hold in stock
rather than what comes through the unit
and jobs
okay any further questions
okay thanks jeff um for presenting that
report
um now going to go along
to page six five four welcome to the
table sarah
thank you mr mayor thank you
uh as you're well aware much of this
budget
um is related to servicing the costs
associated with
our many many meetings
and with this term we have increased the
number of
meetings and the number of committees
in previous term along with
a number of working parties and
additional outside meetings that we also
service
as part of the overall
scope of our area and we also have the
what we call the creative administration
team
no longer called the the typing
department
and they handle all the
brochures flyers advertising general
templated type documents
that are handled both for in-house use
and for public consumption
which is separate from the graphic
design position that's associated
with comms the two working
together in in conjunction on various
projects but their actual type of work
is quite defined and different
um with regards to the overall
envelope of finance we have
um basically stayed within the same
envelope
we did have to obviously cut through the
last annual plan
and covert but we have had
reallocated funding
around the budget hence some of the
decreases and some columns increasing
for an example we have on our budget
lines the four standing committees but
we have eight committees
so the ad
heading actually covers those other four
committees
and will also cover hearings and those
types of meetings that come up
throughout the year
um the
utilities enrolling this year is having
meetings monthly rather than every other
month
and the planning and regulation
committee is from about the middle of
the year expected to
decrease in the number of meetings
required
particularly while the district plan is
running in conjunction
over the next financial year so that
level of service that we will provide to
that department which is just at the
committee level not at their
briefings and their workshops that
they've been having that's
covered under the district plan budget
so we've decreased that so we've
actually reallocated
more in a line where our staff are
actually going to what meetings
but staying within that window
also one of the differences that you may
have noticed
is the merrell project line
that is
is actually comprised of another number
of components
that have been lumped together however
after a discussion with
jeff in the last few days we're going to
split that out
um to better define it so the actual
mayoral office expenses will be
only a few thousand dollars um and
relatively small the bulk of it will be
under a banner of um civic community
events and that will cover things like
the community service awards
and also our citizenship which
is starting up again
this year as far as the actual events go
there are also things like mayoral task
force for jobs
school prize giving some extra trophies
and things some
reads that may come up through the year
that is not associated with anzac
and anzac the budgets there
are primarily for road management and
assist in the rsas
and the reads that we have for that
throughout the district event on that so
you will
see the next budget round
that area defined a little clearer
same grand total but split out a little
bit better
we've already mentioned in the
commentary about the international
relations
um
and happy to take any questions
thank you sarah on page 658
uh just under mural projects you've got
catering
um the taxpayers union delights and
knowing what councillors spend on
food yes meetings we have had requests
and
responses right i just wondered does
this figure
include catering for any other type of
event
or is it just for us this is generally
for
like the next three days of meetings
some of the the larger meetings through
the year like the ltp
as you know on a normal council day
or a committee day it's um pretty light
on the catering of
basically a packet of biscuits um
and that's also why the catering has
virtually gone from the committees
as well and been re-allocated
back there also the
end-of-year function that the council or
end-of-term function that the council
may
have i know last last year you chose not
to
but um so that's also been accounted for
but it is not oh and also if you have
visiting councils come
those types of things that we would get
catering in
but it is primarily for this group
thank you i was just wondering if they
could have been split up into
various categories such as visiting
councils
well we are feeding you at the same time
as we're feeding them because you are
meeting collectively together
it's not that they are meeting staff or
management they are meeting with you
so you are sharing in there so no i
would say it's a little bit difficult to
do the breakdown i wasn't suggesting
pruning
what we would receive yeah but just
reallocating
somewhere else well effectively we are
meeting
where we can with the four neighbouring
councils once a year
hosting it here and once a year them
hosting us
all being well so in the great scheme of
things we're not talking a lot of money
we're talking under a thousand dollars
for those four meetings
well and truly under a thousand dollars
in fact probably under five hundred
dollars for the
the four meetings yeah i think sharon
yeah hold on yes sarah and i have
had a talk about the catering budget and
vera is very very lean
uh we haven't allowed a lot and
we were talking about doubling that
because of
what you're actually referring to is
that a lot of the catering you do
isn't the council it's visiting
uh visiting business and relationships
which we have to
host and so look
i think if the ratepayers association
looked at our books they'll probably
actually add
add money into it based on what they see
so it is very lean to have
five thousand dollars uh when you're
talking about all
the daytime meetings that you have and
we have to cater for
and there are some other events that
we've got coming up with jim spherewell
and others as well that
need to be accounted for somewhere so
we're having a brief conversation about
that the other day so i'll leave
georgetown zero to work out
what the numbers were but my own
personal mural projects it's
slightly no more than five thousand is
the amount that's there and i
i don't i'm not an expensive person in
that regard
so i don't need 39k but i appreciate
what sarah's
it just needs to be reallocated and
appropriately
one more question it's actually around
that we've got new ceo coming
we're a ceo going we've got a lot of
functions that we would normally not
have in a 12-month
period we have our whole around those
and looking in these budgets in my view
we are far too lean i mean we've got 20
years of service of one particular
gentleman that we need to be
um celebrating at the end of his
not just us but staff and so on we are
far too lenient i'm not sure that jim's
farewell is actually accounted for in
this particular budget i'm not sure
where that's
been allocated from it's not and i've
had a conversation with jeff about that
and
we will be allocating for that we need
to
make sure that it's done properly so if
we could leave that to jeff and sarah
but
how that's accounted for but it and i'll
let you know what those costs are
but you'll know what they are so
nothing's being hidden but
it's just not reflecting that here but
it's a good question
[Music]
oh sorry no no it's time it's time we do
it it's all well and good being prudent
and careful but
actually it puts a lot on people and um
we do need to just think about that you
know if we host it at our homes and we
do all those sort of things it's
you know i don't think i don't think
that our ratepayers would really
um be too some may be but too concerned
if we do things properly
uh inappropriately we're not extravagant
in how we do things so
it's making sure that it's not
overloading people as well
in that task so anyway believe geoff and
syria to work without they'll come back
any further questions kirsten
this is probably my question for jeff
actually overall
if if we look at just the direct
expenditure on 606 458
it's 86 000 over forecast
how are you going to reflect that in
commentary
and given that some of this year was
quite exceptional
as well but how are you going to reflect
that back when the rest of the council
was cutting
that we've actually gone up 86 000 total
and direct
expenditure from the forecast
at the bottom of the page which
every other department's tried to either
stay status quo or cut
yeah and the commentary doesn't reflect
those increases at all
you're about 20.3 which is less than
inflation
yeah yeah but other departments have
been asked to cut um
they have been uh used to having a uh us
to cut but they're not too
a lot more than 2.3 percent some of them
this is just a true reflection on cost
and i think
you know when you look at what we cut
out for covert to get to that 1.5
percent and to have only 2.3 on top of
it
i think that's that's a pretty
reasonable uh position again
we wouldn't be explaining this one
because it's not what we consider
significant
it's underneath in inflation okay we're
absolutely on the bare minimum
of operating yeah i'm i'm not
questioning that
even slightly but i mean i'm just
talking about when you look at it from
just a straight laden's point of view in
numbers um
just for example going back to 657
that the training budget doubling nearly
is that because it was halved last year
and it's gone back up
uh that's up the top of the line
training
what was on
6 58 the forecast was 5870 and it's now
10 89. that's that one's for you sarah
oh sorry sir
i can tell you that most of your staff
time
but this is training a training budget
yes which most
of the departments have cut and we'll
have staff time and training
um in the training budget but
now this is training of stuff i think
looking at the budget
we did we did cut the training budgets
and keeping that to a reasonable
medium but that may have come back
in as a maybe an automatic um
reflection postcode so i just need to
check thank you thank you
okay sorry
but a solution for that be the the
comment that jeff made that you
want to bring on some new young people
and do some training this year and and
upskill them i know that's sort of less
than a different that's on the water
unit budget
um this one is um just in the secretary
i can double check
yeah any further questions okay
so um there will be some really
serious suits and some changes to but
it's not going to affect the overall
item and some clarity around the
training as just
it's been requested so that'll come back
as an answer
question so is there any comments anyone
wishes to make
houston just quickly and the budget's
super super important in what we're
doing but how we communicate it is just
as important
because people are looking at this with
a fine tooth comb so
we need to state why things have
increased so if there's an increase on
forecast from last year
we've got to give a clear explanation in
commentary going forward and
that wasn't reflected in this governance
report there were like five different
areas hadn't been reflected changed from
forecast so
if that can be reflected in the report
that would be really good
sandra
sanji can use the mic please thank you
page 657
um corporate management insurance we've
got a new
line and then list pool call funds
have gone down from 300 000 to 60 and
stay at about that level
so is that a reallocation of some things
in here or what what's happened to you
yeah i think i think just ignore the
insurance life for
now we've done it across the council
to check whether our insurance is but
that was an amount put in here for an
increase in insurance
uh we just need to check i've got the
finance team looking at that our
insurance looks like it's about ten
percent
above you look better add up all the
accounts across the board
overall we're 10 above and that's about
where we wanted to be
so what's being indicated from our
insurance company
brokers okay
uh council sorry did you have a fifth
question counselor
sorry did you have a further question no
no just council duty
you use your mate please thank you he's
asked us about the honorarium please
[Music]
john 6 this is your
all elected members um this is all
elected members
remuneration and because we can't
forecast
uh how much the authority is going to
increase
or amend future we have looked at
burl information and used an average of
three percent
based on what what elected members are
receiving today
plus three percent going forward so in
future years that will be
adjusted but we don't know until
that june may june any changes from the
remuneration authority so we've had to
do our
best estimates there based on burl and
that three percent increase
if anyone was looking at that they'd be
wanting to know what that was for so
that is against um
yeah the there's one line
for councillors and mia and then there's
the other lines reflected in the
community boards
as well so there are 35 members overall
[Music]
thank you okay
is there any further questions any
comments
but sarah just on our behalf of your
budget
so thank you for all that you do to to
support us you and your team the
governance team
we're exceptionally well supported it's
been a
last year particularly was it well all
of us was the most trying year but
keeping us all functioning and making
sure that we were connected with
meetings and
have been well supported thank you we
really appreciate them particularly
as we've gone through the ceo
appointment process i know you've been
very integral to me in terms of
support and advice making sure we have
the process right and on track so i
just want to say thanks for what you do
to keep us on track and
we do have a very lean budget and and
that
you know we've just been talking about
that but also
all the questions that come through as
well the prudence is also important
but there are some aspects that we've
probably just got to be a bit more
reflective on because
probably are just a bit too prudent so
in some places but there's nothing wrong
with that but it's just making sure that
we've got adequate amounts there at
times so thank you sarah for what you do
i appreciate your comments mr mayor and
if you thought last year was busy you
were right
we used to manage about 200 odd meetings
per year on your behalf
now we're doing 300 plus meetings per
year on your behalf
with the same number of staff yeah
you're doing a great
we appreciate it sarah thank you very
much
um and supportive stuff
there's a there's a lot more meetings
than people actually realize that go on
so um sandra have you got your
pin up for a reason for the bottom of
page 660 where you've got the valuation
you've got woody
sefton advisory group we've got three
advisory groups
in a community board should they be all
community boards
okay teams well i think we've got
to a good point today um
[Laughter]
well we could but i think in fairness to
him we should leave it till tomorrow